[Musique]
il avait sans doute déjà entendu parler
de jacques mesrine
et pour cause par la série de films à
grand succès qui a été fait sur lui même
la nouvelle génération connaît le nom et
le destin de ce bandit france est
devenue une véritable icône numéro un
jacques mesrine surnommé l'homme aux
mille visages est rapidement devenu
l'ennemi public numéro un recherché pour
faits de vols à main armée enlèvement ce
criminel très charismatique a fasciné
les français dans les années 70 arrêté à
plusieurs reprises
il devient ensuite célèbre pour ses
évasions spectaculaires il en est à sa
troisième évasion tout aussi
spectaculaire les jeunes que les offres
des états où kim et non à sa cavale une
cavale d'un an et demi qui fondera fin
le 2 novembre 1979 porte de clignancourt
à paris lorsqu'il est abattu par des
policiers au volant de sa voiture une
voiture grise s'immobilise criblé de
balles à l'intérieur tu es net
jacques mesrine une histoire incroyable
qui a décidé de nous raconter vous
nommez rinne son fils ce soir sur le
plateau de touche pas à mon poste
merci d'être avec nous bruno mérine
merci d'être là nous vous en prie en
plus on a un petit à petit en un an
connaît une période est personne encore
moins tous les deux livré et oui mon
père votre père et mon père qui vous
êtes vous êtes vous un coach qui vous
habite à côté tu es mon père mes voisins
et il paraît que mon père vous emmerde
parce qu'il garde toujours sa voiture
sur un parking non marie leila parking
commun avec le avec le mien mais bien
d'accord ça va il m'ennuie pas du tout
c'est vrai il est très discrète mais
très discret très fière de son fils vous
concernant merci beaucoup d'être là
alors bruno dit merci déjà de vouloir
témoigner chez nous vous avez été levée
par votre père jusqu'à vos trois ans oui
par mes parents exactement pas par wii
puis des partis en prison
oui vous avez leur grandi chez vos
grands parents comment se vit une
enfance quand on est le fils de l'ennemi
public numéro 1 il faut savoir que
chaque mairie c'est vraiment c'est le
plus grand gangster de toute l'histoire
de france voilà comment on vit est ce
qu'à l'école vos petits camarades savent
et qui vous étiez des votes pas quand je
suis à trois heures non oui mais après
on va dire continent en prison à partir
de manière à partir du moment qu'ils
aient connue est vraiment dans les
médias regarder les années 70 cela je
fais appel à peu près huit ans là bas
donc dans la cour de récréation les gens
je vois mon père et moi je me retrouve
au milieu de mes camarades je peux pas
dire qui je suis
souvent j'ai eu des fous non pour sa
part facilement y avec le directeur qui
savaient qui j'étais en fait ouais ouais
mais tu es il est question c'est est-ce
que ça est-ce que ça posait des
problèmes aux directeurs de vous prendre
dans les halls ou pas du tout non aucun
moment non d'accord aucun moment il n'a
jamais été déléguée de parents j'imagine
non il a été délégué par an une tendance
attendue à deux noms de ligue 1 en plus
des ternes en france âge camarades ne le
savais pas dans personne même les
parents des seuls moments où ils ont su
c'est qu'on ait mis à l'abri dans un
village en savoie pour mettre à l'abri
des médias des flics et compagnie pour
qu'elle soit peinard quoi plus que
puisqu'on dit on va dire normalement
plus ou moins là tout me village de
savoie le savait mais personne n'en
parlait et qu'est ce que vous répondez à
vos petits camarades au professeur quand
ils essaient de savoir ce que faisait
votre papa mais moi j'ai appris pendant
des années à dire que mon père était
mort comme ça c'était plus simple ah
ouais saviez sam éviter d'avoir des
réponses alors après les gens moment
2 comme il était mort et que les fêtards
alors des fois je fais du hip hop
zigzags et ça passait kouame jeu
compliqué le plus dur c'est de se
laisser dire la vérité en fait quand on
est le gamin avec 30 on nous dit qu'on
appelle redire la direction fait comment
quoi alors comment comment on vit son
enfance quand son papa est en cavale
comment vous voyez comment vous arrivez
à le voir comment vous ne serez pas
parler comment tu vas arriver à le world
sera dans mon livre way sera de retenue
mais non stationnaire il ya pas pour
possibilité non plus un vaste choix de
produits risque que deux prôné à ce qui
est juste ce qu'il prenait des risques
pour vous voir pour vous voir ses
enfants - oui oui oui mais pas deux fois
deux fois mais cette fois il était
déguisé forcément comme les deux mois je
vais une fois je l'aï pas reconnu en le
rendant bien sûr doit gare iv avait plus
ou moins dépanneur en fin de compte le
dépanneur c'était mon père
ouais oui nicole vous êtes arrivé à
nouer un lien très fort avec lui oui au
lieu de tout armement ça a commencé à
dire pendant des années pendant les deux
premières années parce que comme il
était dans les cas très haute sécurité
c'est thérapeutique de de le voir en
fait au départ lui l'avait pas l'euro
visite au départ et que là donc ça bien
non un an et demi à peu près dans les
moments de cavale il arrivait on n'a pas
tant que ça en amont maintenant c'était
vraiment exceptionnel ce jour de
deux moments c'était beaucoup plus le
courrier en fait un courrier pratiquant
par jour et lui c'est pareil ils adorent
à écrire dans cadre et après elle et les
meilleurs moments de complicité c'est
malheureux à dire mais c'était au
parloir d'éclater au de sécurité c'est
ça et c'est pas le meilleur endroit pour
un gamin oui pour moi c'était quand même
le meilleur moment parce que j'avais mon
père fasse alors à quoi ils étaient
quelque el papa jacques marinées ce qui
vous disaient qu'ils vous adorable ils
vous disaient qu'ils vous aimez quand
vous venez au parloir
oui oui vous voyez vous mais ils le
disent à sa manière mais au moins il est
extrêmement fier de moi je sais pas
pourquoi on vous dit que vous étiez un
enfant qui fait ça donc oui oui vous
travaillez bien l'école comment
travaille t il tenir le pôle il fallait
pas que je fasse des bêtises
ouais il fallait que je sois un bon
petit fils parce que c'est sa mère kim
élevé il fallait que je sois un bon
gamin à l'école pour pas qu'on fasse
aucun reproche possible moi j'étais pas
non plus mais pas les s qui est-ce qui
est ce qu'il est arrivé de vous gronder
parce que vous aviez fait une bêtise il
m'a engueulé une seule fois pourquoi
samuel seule fois parce que fournisseur
d'os mobile est allé avoir 14 ans donc
là l'âge d'avoir une mobylette
moi je voyais tous mes petits copains en
avoir une et cetera je dirai à mon père
un coach aimerait bien en avoir une et
caetera et je sais pas pourquoi ma soeur
et lui avaient à peu monté la tête etc
et il signe un manga les haut-parleurs
clamé m avait engueulé quoi et dix
minutes après leur garde un peu comme ça
fait fallait pas grave la mode play tu
leur as quand même voilà à bombay mais
bon c'était un petit os et non mais moi
moi c'était important je m'étais jamais
fait engueuler par un père et ses sacs
pleins et chance il vous faisait peur ou
pas non non pas du monroe s'épanouir
oui nicolas n'y avait aucune raison de
ma part et vous aviez la peur au ventre
pour votre papa non c'est ça oui et
quelle information vous arriviez à avoir
de temps qu'il était c'est malheureux ce
que je vais dire mais tant qu'il était
au quartier de sécurité n'est pas
inquiet en fait c'est ça mais parce que
je vais grandir c'est magnifique je ne
vais pas dire qu'ils étaient en sécurité
mais les travaux de sécurité donc voilà
il risquait pas grand chose quelque part
par là
hé les conditions de capitaux de
sécurité que tu es encore d'autres
sujets mais quand il est en cavale
je me disais parce qu'il ya quelques
enfants cavallin bien sûr on revient on
retient la dernière quand il était en
cavale à chaque cabane j'étais angoissé
et 15 l'appartement de la famille et des
nouvelles mais la route grand mère vous
aviez des nouveaux amis en grand mère
oui oui il arrivé à vous à lui dire ça
va on avait dû manière d'une autre il
avait des contacts
d'accord vous avez contre oui oui est-ce
que vous avez vu les longs métrages sur
votre père notamment avec vincent cassel
je sais que vous qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé suis même dedans même dedans
vous avez vous l'avez aimé vous l'avait
adoubée non non les deux les deux
chiffres sont des très bons films ou des
mois il émaille a pas photo vincent
cassel superbement voilà c'est vraiment
deux super film après historiquement ça
reste du cinéma les moments où il ya les
petits raccourcis les petites rues il ya
un conflit ce qu'on retrouve ce n'est
pas le seul le vrai dans la réalité il
ya une voiture qui expose alors qu'il
n'y a aucune raison de faire exploser
une voiture alors que tout le monde leur
recherche
voilà ça fait un peu plus si les
matraques à l'annuler alors alors juste
jouer qu'on regarde un exprimé sa honte
à toi qui montrent son évasion
impressionnante
c'était de la prison de la santé vous
dites que quand il s'évade et vous étiez
inquiet le voilà à la santé la prison
dont on ne s'évade bas et à peine un an
après le début de sa détention
jacques mirin et ses complices
réussissent l'impossible
là monsieur bonsoir et oui jacques
mesrine s'est évadé même si ici on
n'aime pas trop les formules et la
sensationnelle on est bien obligé de
dire que l'ennemi public numéro 1 et
depuis ce matin en liberté s'est évadé
effectivement de la prison avec deux
autres complices et il avait simplement
réussi à se procurer une arme factice il
a simulé une prise d'otages et puis a
finalement de façon très audacieuse or
il a réussi à passer par dessus le mur
un peu comme dans dans des films de
série b alors on déjà ce monsieur
raconte n'importe quoi
il a évolué bien c'est bien ça pour
lancer déjà déjà les armes n'étaient pas
factice d'accord pour commencer
deuxièmement il n'y a pas de prise
d'otages il appelle 5 réseautage que mon
père a enfermé tous les maths on a trop
de sécurité dans une cellule
non c'est fermé coupet mais c'est fermé
je te dirai pas non c'est pas une prise
celui ci lui ce média l'école et qui là
il a retourné le quartier au dessus de
sécurité contre comme n'entendez rien
quelqu'un qui est un fait que la
sécurité des données comme il voulait on
n'entendait pas les gens enfermés comme
ça il faut les aider comme il voulait on
les entend les pauvres alors un mail
il avait un code d'honneur à ne pas tuer
oui ce qu'il a toujours respecté et de
tuer personne
alors si qu'il a on n'a pas les mêmes
données il a au canada en pleine fuite
on dit qu'il a tué 2 garde-chasse oui
voilà en pleine forêt avec deux seuls
meurtre retenues contre jacques mairie
oui c'est plus compliqué que ça alors en
fait c'est pas lui qui les a tués mais
c'est son complice d'accord et comme on
était au canada et que chaque personne
s'il est condamné si le prend à peu près
sont 10 cents par part par cadavres on
va dire moi sacrifier les termes mon
père à faire j'enrage études je rajoute
une comme ça on sera tous les deux
complices soient là quand même
oui mais bon pour vous il n'a jamais tué
personne il a tué les maquereaux adéquat
vous en parlez bruit marie laure n'a pas
dans l'instinct de mort ça c'est dans sa
jeunesse elle s'en serait oui on revient
un gros vient d'algérie il y aura encore
une prostituée qui s'est fait balafré
par ama pro mais le maquereau et voilà
il a une hôtellerie
ils voulaient ils respecter les femmes
ah oui oui on se disait voilà j'ai
jamais s'en prendre à une femme mais on
n'aurait jamais c'est un gentleman avec
les familles les ministères sont
électeurs un gagnant tom est un prince
mais combien d'enfants par nous 3 bonne
et moi j'ai grandi dans une ville
pardon de dire ça avant d'habiter au mur
où j'habitais dans une ville qui
s'appelle marley le roi
oui et c'est là d'un dernier endroit où
derniers appartements le dernier
appartement et le jour 2 qu'il a été
assassiné il allait parler la direction
de l'appartement
si je peux vous engagez vous en parler
c'est bon d'entendre ça donne c'est
votre père etc
et c'est quoi le souvenir que vous
gardez de votre père le souvenir
ouais j'en ai pas qu'elle passerait ça
serait super simple
de souvenirs la première fois que je les
vis au quartier de sécurité et le
deuxième souvenir
ce seront associés là vous êtes fiers de
votre père oui oui oui c'est pas dans
pas dans l'excessif moi je suis moins
fan que les fans de mon père en fait
c'est vrai qu'il était très populaire
mais malicki mais en ce moment c'est
même incroyable c'est sans fin et sans
fin oui en avant on a parlé de votre
relation avec votre père en prison mais
quel était votre relation en dehors de
la prison au niveau physique
est ce que c'est un papa qui vous
faisait vous avez ce que dans votre vie
vous avez réussi à avoir une relation
physique des câlins des la tendresse
dans votre nom dans le job à tout non
même quand vous l'avez vu le peu de fois
peut-être que vous l'avez vu dans la
réalité
non non c'était à stetten sh blanc bon
bruno avec ça ça me manquera toujours
déjà d'avoir un papa normal de cukurca
ligne passée déjà papoul d'avoir un papa
peut pas dire paranormal c'est encore
pire
alors si tu es pas de seins ne fait pas
des enfants non plus non non je n'ai pas
aux histoires de drogue c'est pas des
assassins c'est un voyou alors on le
jour 2 de son assassinat
comment vous l'apprenez mais en finale
il ya même pas le pas sur la photo il ya
27 ans de procédure pour obtenir un
non-lieu à la fin donc alors on va pas
dans le documentaire
il ya un policier qui était sur les
lieux qui dit on pouvait pas on est
obligé de tirer les gars je t'ai mirin
s'était pas n'importe qui on a été
obligés de tirer
qu'est ce que vous dites à ça alors moi
je dis qu'à mais que enfermé dans une
bmw attachée à sa ceinture les deux
mains sur le volant
face à quatre tireurs d'élite qui sont à
3 mètres de lui avec des fusils
l'insolent d'armé et avec une trentaine
de flics tout autour si mon père est
encore dangereux faut m'expliquer là
comment vous l'avez appris j'ai appris
moi j'allais j'étais donc à l'abri dans
mon petit village de savoir et j'ai pour
la toussaint je vais sur la tombe de mon
grand père je suis sur la route avec ma
grand-mère ont heureusement ma grand
mère n'avait pas d'autoradio
donc on arrive on arrive on arrive à
clichy à l'appartement familial et dans
la rue des centaines des centaines de
personnes et qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe voilà tout le
monde me saute dans les bras d'un père
est mort son père est mort
saviez à quel âge j'avais à dire quinze
ans parce que j'avais 14 ans et l'evac
21 quelques jours quoi vous avez ses
victimes sur vous avez pris la nouvelle
robin des textiles et j'ai appris la
nouvelle je monte tout de suite à
l'appartement 3d mais la télévision pour
fonds veut dire mais je rêve au japon
voilà la police n'ont pas la police
j'entends beaucoup parler en ce moment
des violences policières etc c'est
encore un autre sujet donc j'en veux à
broussard et sa petite bande de gaza
commissaire broussard sur l' enquête
pendant des années des années leurs
voeux à ce mec là et à sa petite bande
qui ont reçu l'ordre de tuer mon père
oui penser qu'il aura donné ordre de
tuer votre père je voulais pas mais
voulait qu'ils retournent en prison
non mais c'est en entendant prison il va
refaire encore du spectacle au dernier
procès qu'il a fait tout le monde
applaudissait
non non il voulait plus d'un mais camus
parce que le danger pouvait de mon père
c'est ça qui l'a conduit quelque part sa
fin quand on devient un concert
populaire ça c'est pas bon ça bah ouais
c'est ça ben c'est parce qu'il était
très aimée mais les mêmes des sondages
sur lui pour sa part sur sa popularité
oui delphine alors justement c'est lui
l'homme de l'année par paris malsaine
marque parismatch utilisateurs étaient
sixièmes et oui élu homme de l'année
on découvre ouais c'est ce à quoi oui
c'était votre papa donc vous l'aimiez
mais est-ce qu'un jour vous lui en avait
voulu des choix qu'il a fait dans sa vie
parce qu'au final il faut pas en vouloir
à la police ou quoi que ce soit ses
propres choix
on est content si je dois en vouloir mon
père que c'est face à szczesny de cette
manière là je serai fier des [ __ ] de
fils pour un méchant médias face à illac
tellement plus fort au prix au prix fort
il faut pas en vouloir à mon père et ses
passes possibles et est populaire parce
que surtout il avait un engagement en
politique
oui il est qu à chasser et d'ailleurs
les gens ne mesurent pas être dans la
prison c'était une prison dans la prison
dans une prière aux droites ce qui m'a
toujours frappé avec vous c'est que en
fait il était psychologiquement ils
n'avaient pas craqué parce que la chasse
à broyer les gens c'est sûr ça qui
s'évade et cathartique sécurité c'est
quand même le premier motif de son
évasion parce qu'il est dit si je reste
comme ça encore cinq ans mais je serai
brisé je serais cassé et voilà et en
plus c'est une évasion comme seule elle
en à peine plus fort au canada
bruno télé payante dacca
la casa de la 4e voie d'allah lui et ses
unités spéciales de correction vous
assurer que c'est là il va sur les vélos
6 1
renault est ce que vous avez songé un
moment à faire la même carrière que
votre père quand on perd son papa où il
est pilote d'hélicoptère de france
militaire on m'a dit à l'époque bien tu
es devenu pilote pour faire rêver les
tempèrent problème c'est que mon père
était déjà mort depuis quelques années
donc je suis devenu magicien
quelque part ce n'est pas loin de mon
père tout le monde sa cavale il
s'appelle bruno après je veux dire
pendant lâcheront de 16 à 18 ans oui
j'ai été presque tous les soirs garde à
vue oui vous parlez vous êtes en garde a
nommé un moment je commence à avoir ma
photo dans tous les commissariats et je
commence à me dire mais c'est pas bon ça
ah ouais vous disais c'est pas bon non
non c'est pas pas du tout cherché non
être pressée pas de fierté mais c'est
avec lego lesquels suis dit je suis fier
d'avoir été bonne et je suis fier
d'avoir été en prison on n'y a pas de
fierté
vous avez la science elles s'établissent
à lui gardé par des gens voilà qui vous
dit ton père tous les bords dans tous
les sens ouais vous avez toujours dix
ans élite et vous avez du don oui
toujours
oui nous allons pas tirer des problèmes
non non non aujourd'hui une vie
tranquille vous vivez à côté de chez mon
père oui oui vous êtes tranquille et à
une embrouille et la toubib c'est ça
aujourd'hui vous êtes magiciens
ouais ouais pas aujourd'hui depuis 25
ans pensez que votre père aurait été
fier de vous je pense qu'il est fier de
moi
il est fier de vous serez venus voir le
spectacle je pense qu'il la regarde là
où vous vous êtes dit magicien numéro un
oui pourquoi ça c'est pas ma faute
j'étais plus jeune pilote de france
numéro 1 magie cette famille votre père
était le numéro un donc vous êtes laissé
assez de fait ville exactement vous êtes
tous des numéros haché demerin non faire
quel que soit le domaine
non non il avait des enfants oui qu'est
ce que vous leur dites ils vous parlent
devriez vous parle de lui une fille vous
parle de votre papa de son grand père
bien sûr web on parle mais pas tant que
ça pas tant que ça non elle a été voir
le film we ouais ben merci en tout cas
j'ai offert les dvd et tous que bien sûr
m